-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#ItShouldBeIllegalTo stories
from you guys.
This first one here is
from @wantpeaceforall.
He says, "It should be illegal
to post sweaty pictures
on social media.
We get it, Karen. You work out."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You still look the same, Karen!
This one is from @cj710.
-Ooh, cj710.
-He's 7'10".
He's like a gentle giant.
Yeah, 710. 7'10".
He says, "It should be illegal
to let Netflix ask,
'Are you still watching?'
Yes, Netflix,
I am in fact still watching
my eighth straight episode
of 'Grey's Anatomy.'
Leave me alone!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you!
Power saver mode on your TV.
-Leave me be.
This is from @lizzieisbusy.
-Oh, she is.
[ Laughter ]
She's very busy.
She says, "It should be illegal
to give me only one sauce
when I order
a 10-piece chicken nugget.
I require a minimum of one sauce
per three nuggets!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's simple math!
-Illegal.
-This one's from @dontatme --
-Oh, well, then don't.
[ Laughter ]
-30. She says,
"It should be illegal
to write checks
at the grocery store.
Get a debit card
and be confused about
whether to use your chip or
swipe it like the rest of us."
[ Applause ]
No, actually we only do --
sorry, we only do --
-Chips?
-What's that?
No, we only check your swipes.
-Okay, so I should swipe it.
-No, we take checks.
-Wait, you take checks?
-Just put the chip in
and wait for the beep.
Don't remove it.
-Okay, wait a second.
-Don't take it out!
Seriously, a lot of screwed-up
things will happen.
-I'm not gonna take it out.
-Oh, aisle four
was just destroyed.
Please stop touching the chip.
-All right, I'm taking it --
-You got to sign it.
You have to sign it.
You have to pay for the person
behind you as well.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @megan18495602.
Very easy.
How come you never tweet me,
you idiot?
-Well, why don't you
just tweet me --
-Just do -- it's so simple.
-Okay, what's your name
on Twitter?
-@Jimmy2419149 -- sorry, 1-5-3.
You're, like, not my friend.
I'm unfollowing you.
-No, I'll get it.
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
Give it to me again.
One more time.
-What were you just doing?
-I was erasing numbers.
-Were you on Whatsapp?
-I was on my calculator.
I was writing on --
[ Laughter ]
I was on the wrong app.
I just learned how to erase
on a calculator.
3-5-8-4.
-Just do it the way
in the rhythm.
2-3-4, blah, blah, blah.
-Yeah.
-Don't do it in twos.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's my number.
9-2, 3-6-4.
-1-9, 1-4.
Wait, what?
-How am I supposed to --
-1-1-1-9-9-1-1-1-9-1-1.
[ Laughter ]
-4-8-4-8-9-3-8-7.
-This is from @Megan18495602 --
-Empire.
[ Laughter ]
-She says, "It should be illegal
to wear pants so tight
that your front butt shows."
[ Laughter ]
No, come on, hey.
-Hey, come on.
-Come on.
-Come on, front butt.
That's rude.
-This one's from
@agillenwater98.
-Agillenwater98?
-Not Jillen Water.
-Gillenwater?
-Oh, Gillenwater.
-A -- This is from
agillenwater98.
-A gill in water? Maybe it's
like a fish reference.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
No -- Gillen, G-I-L-L-E-N.
-Like Gilligan
from "Gilligan's island"?
-No, that's Gilligan,
what you just said.
So, it's Gillen.
But I see where
you made the mistake.
-Yeah, yeah, I made the mistake.
I misheard.
I thought you said Gilligan.
-You thought that I said
"Gilligan's Island."
-Yes.
-But instead I said
agillenwater98.
-Well, Gilligan lives, is --
he's surrounded by water.
-No spoilers.
I've never seen the show.
-Are you serious?
[ Laughter ]
All right,
I don't want to ruin it.
They go for a three-hour cruise.
-Is that where they go
and their fantasies happen?
Just don't spoil it.
This is from @agillenwater98.
He says,
"It should be illegal to sneeze
more than twice in a row.
You get that one 'bless you.'
After that, you're on your own."
-Oh, cold blooded.
[ Applause ]
-Then you're in Satan's hands.
-Yeah, oh.
-This one's from @margesondanny.
He says, "It should be illegal
to give me a merchant receipt,
a custom receipt,
and a third receipt every time
I go out to dinner.
What am I supposed to do with
all this documentation
for my nachos?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Illegal!
-I signed customer copy!
-This last one's
from @mariabrandont.
She says, "It should be illegal
to listen to Adele 'Someone like
You' more than five times a day.
The whole dorm already knows
you broke up with Josh.
Move on, girl!"
-Oh!
-There you have it. Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.